what's up guys Vincent oshana here with
valuetainment I'm here with Nick and
Kelly from Palm Beach stilts uh Nick
I'll go to you first how you feeling for
the event are you having a good time
listen anytime I can provide any fun and
entertainment for anybody I'm always
there for I love it so much we're having
a great time nice Kelly are you into
tall guys or short guys
both what wait what left no I went I
Told You So how about how does it feel
just walking around and looking down on
everybody's head you guys know who's
wearing a two pan who is not
I have spotted a few already today yeah
yeah for sure any any females with any
any weird hairdos on the back I'll leave
them alone I'll leave them alone laughs
[Music]